the craziest High I ever experienced was
the toad Venom in Mexico City it was
crazy you're not licking a toad no the
50s or 60s some zoologists wrote a book
on frogs and toads and then there was
just one sentence in that book about
like the combustion of the poison of the
bufal various toad creates a serotonin
derivative so some Maniac in the 80s was
like I'm gonna find this toad smoke the
Venom and see if I trip and they're
gnarly toes eight rats and stuff they're
like the Dwayne The Rock Johnson of
toads and uh but my dad just died of
cancer so I went there for some like Eat
Pray Love kind of chip and I was like
talking directly to my dad and balling
crying but I came out of it it felt like
um emotionally ejaculating
it felt like this Great Purge of all
this tension and build up and stress
from watching my dad deteriorate into
death and uh it really really really was
a cathartic and therapeutic experience